good morning this is inking live an hour
of business and economic news from the
heart of the city
sri lanka has asked the international
monetary fund for urgent help following
a financial crisis that has engulfed the
island state it's halted its debt
payment stoking fears that its economy
could be about to collapse protests have
erupted in the country over food
shortages and soaring fuel prices all
joining me now from the sri lankan
capital colombo is matasa jaffaji chair
of the advocate institute and elected
director of the colombo stock exchange
morning to you sir how did sri lanka
come to be in this state
well uh leading up to a change in
government this new government came in
in 2019 country's economy was slowing
because there were many macroeconomic
shocks that
had happened before that and we were
carrying a lot of debt the new
government with the aim of stimulating
the economy put across some
very aggressive tax cuts they lost about
35 percent of their revenue and then
kobe hit us
so when kobe hit us uh international
eurobond started trading at about a 30
percent discount to book value
and the rating was cut and we were
unable to roll over our debt
and kobe continued and
you know commodity prices and the
ukrainian war came so we simply ran out
of reserves
and we had to put a cessation a
temporary suspension on debt service
payments
now around a fifth of sri lanka's debt
is owed to japan and to china how likely
are they to show forbearance
well we have already requested them the
bilateral creditors to do some kind of
deferment
the problem is that both the japanese
and the chinese don't generally like to
do restructuring japan is a member of
the paris club china is not a member of
the paris club so because of the
precedence that
will be set for other
detonations they have been extremely
reluctant to do it
so i'm afraid that it's going to be a
tough negotiation process going ahead
what about uh india i gather india has
been offering bilateral aid
yes they have been a country of last
resort that we have turned to and as a
indian fighter foreign minister said
neighbors first so they are going out of
their way to help us
sri lanka has never defaulted on its
debts in its history despite three
decades of civil war do you fear that
that is likely this time
yeah sir they have already indicated
that they are going to
have a temporary suspension
and yesterday basically there was a
coupon payment due on euro bonds on two
euro bonds and there is a 30 day grace
period on that coupon period
so technically we we have not paid on
the due date but we will not be in
default till 30 days thereafter
now president
pax yesterday announced a cabinet
reshuffle in which he removed two of his
brothers and nephew from cabinet is that
going to be enough to assuage some of
the anger that's being seen on the
streets
uh well basically uh you know the anger
they are portraying it with the hashtag
saying gota go home
and gotha is the name of the president
so the fact that few rajapaksas have not
been reappointed
probably will have some impact but the
key
message that the crowds are calling for
is for the president to go home so that
remains unresolved
you mentioned just now that uh obviously
the pandemic exacerbated difficulties in
the economy for example in depriving sri
lanka of tourist revenues do you worry
that there are other emerging economies
that are likely to face a similar crunch
yes so
we will be first
one to have defaulted for this year but
it is expected that there are many many
other economies who are in a very
vulnerable position and with u.s
interest rates going up outlook for many
emerging market
issuers is going to be very challenging
all right matasa jaffaji thank you very
much indeed for joining me today it's
much appreciated
thank you